ball throw world's huh
I kind of need those for stuff and
things namely masturbation it's kind of
like my pride and joy at the moment
please get away from the lady kitties
please stop your molestation needs to
end spike fall in space Oh Oh God my
balls and everything else down there
mostly my balls is what I'm worried
about
but a heap and help and a dick is also
never mind ignore the fact that I said
he'd been helping him dick yeah God nice
enough to slice open my butthole for me
made it to earth exactly as I expected
descending from space another spike hope
I don't tear my grundle open oh yeah
rough swing Janu caught me on the fly
did you well [ __ ] you impale me by my
brain my big smart brain that I was
about to brag about hey [ __ ] I'm gonna
get this one I've never seen the game
like this oh I'm only sliced open my
mouth to master gnam feel so
accomplished for throw neon it seems
about the same as all the sword throws
yeah that's what I thought about that
whoops oh god I'm sorry
sorry JB's mom got nothing against you
personally
because I don't know you personally god
dingus damn it huh
suck on that and you well I'll just give
you a warning I don't actually want to
win or nothing I'll just give you a
freakin warning look at this oh it's so
bro [ __ ]
Oh Frick my dick ah blam my ass son of a
[ __ ]
ha [ __ ] Oh God let me aah
Frick god damn it I lost my helmet [ __ ]
TV bye son apparently oh it's a
legitimate TV road well that was
probably anterior to what I was [ __ ]
this is not good
try this again but more slowly and
carefully because that's the nature of
this game slowly and carefully how my
grundle now but how in the world that
was floating midair it's like the
bowling game at the theme park oh god I
was not ready I'm a pro but you need to
give me warning look at this Oh can't
get these moves Vikki me oh so I'm the
best look out world here comes the pro
number one polar son-of-a-bitch
CAIR impossible drunkies oh lordy just
plow through his stop ramming your skull
into the butthole of my sleigh that's
not how that works kitty you don't get
extra credit but kisser even though
breathe yeah that was my disagree over
there wait five if you win what happens
if I do this start twerking freeze fall
level one beginner press Z to eject all
right fine then I don't know what I'm
supposed to oh this is not seem
appropriate
I must find I was not ready yeah I've
never seen something like this wow that
probably broke my hip
Wow I'm pissed
it's like a trampoline except when I
land on it oh I was gonna rip your head
right off there buddy boo ha they'll
never well my next sure can take a lot
of trauma I took a lot of courses after
they reattached it 17 times on the
previous attempts well I don't think I
could have given myself more stuck in
this environment huh
this is perfectly executed to be such a
prick to me blue dragon not too far this
time
this seems almost delightful was I
supposed to go this way duck how boink
easy to survive when you're as good as
me at things and stuff did they not know
that markiplier was playing this amazing
level ha I sure I'm great at good I'm
always broke the elevator but not that
much because I am good at games I'm
gonna press that button look at me like
a boss not even a problem for me
markiplier because of how good I am at
things up I go oh look it's more things
to go that's not gonna be a problem
I ain't even bothered by that what they
think is a problem for me markiplier
well I did not press that button she
goddamnit I look so good I was doing so
good God yeah I'm ball throw get more
ball yeah nothing just like my life
well that is weird why are poon dodge
pro three another one of these I'm still
alive [ __ ] I seem to be stick maybe I
could wiggle out of here eventually well
that went further up my rectum
let's get another one of these huh you
think you're bad look at this oh hey
kids how are you doing
time for an educational lesson on what
can't can and cannot go through your
body I'll carry this with me for the
rest of my life just like the guilt that
burns inside of me oh god I'm gonna make
well that stops me hey kid get down I'm
like the government and you're like
society Hey ha ha markiplier is getting
political hey I made it ok cool
well [ __ ] this has been happy wheels
highlights thanks for watching if you
want to see more happy wheels right now
check the description or click the
annotation for the full happy wheels
playlist and if you want to see more
happy wheels in the future please click
the like button to let me know thanks
again everyone and as always I will see
you in the next video bye bye